uh question four part one also might
have made you spin out right now by the
way can i just say you know when people
like it can be kind of like oh i've
never seen a question like that before i
shouldn't be expected to answer a
question like that
i've got news here and i've said this
before the questions that you haven't
seen before
are the most valuable ones they're the
ones where we can really determine do
you really know what's going on or are
you just going through an algorithm
through a series of steps that you've
memorized for a particular question you
do step one two three four five and get
an answer out this doesn't match
right you're expecting something cause
this plus something inside that that's
what you usually get from auxiliary
angle
as you can see all you need to do is
evaluate that and you do get there
eventually right but that little
difference is us trying to sort out do
you just totally freak out when you see
that and not know what to do or do you
have
the patience and the person to work
once you have evaluated
this cos theta plus 60 degrees out it
comes right
you combine your cos terms
uh there's your sine term and there's my
expansion of the
particular
form that they've given us
okay so it'll be nice and it gives you
an acute angle you can see i've got my r
cos theta my r sine theta
i work out r in this case even though
like yeah you could write it as root 12
you can see that actually taking out
the root four is useful to you because
it makes this step over here easier
right when you're actually working out
what cos theta and sine theta are you
can
determine what theta is conclusively
graceful
okay
quick question
uh it's the square root of a squared
plus b squared
which is nine plus three
what which is 12
so once you've got your
value for r and your value for uh sorry
that's a bit naughty this should be this
should be alphas sorry
uh once you've got your
shift right you've changed the phase
there's the auxiliary angle right there
okay
and you use that for this next part now
again there's a bit of a trick right and
i am i did you the favor of drawing your
attention to this restriction you
probably saw the 90
you might have forgotten
that it's not inclusive of the boundary
so when you solve
there's only one solution in
range but even the solution arranged
is excluded by the domain so there are
no real solutions
okay
okay
you should dars you should doris you
should
you're 11.
you're 11.
already
i'll wait it's okay
okay excellent
now i've told you guys before when you
get given a um a hyperbola i like to
treat it like a hyperbola
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
multiplying through by the square which
would give you this
and you can solve this
just the same
you get exactly the same result i prefer
to flex my muscles to think about like i
know what this is meant to look like
roughly i need to have an asymptote
negative 2.
my asymptote is still at sorry i should
say x is negative 2. my asymptote is
still at y equals zero right
and all i want to do
is solve for this intersection point
that's the boundary up there
right
that's gonna be minus five on four all
of this part is okay because obviously
it's less than four and then all of this
part is okay to the left
of the point of detection that i found
so there's your pair of values and the
inequalities that you get don't forget
it's all not and because there's no
number that's simultaneously less than
negative 2 and greater than negative
504.